that's been slightly pushed back on by
both sides they're very keen to say
they've been in intense negotiations now
for
a number of days if not weeks and they
really do see a deal by the end of the
week as a possibility but how many times
adam have you and i sat here and talked
about
the possibility of a deal being done the
reality is it needs to happen now if
it's going to happen
and if it doesn't happen it looks pretty
bad for all sides no one really wants
the uk
to formally walk away without some kind
of agreement
but interestingly now michelle barnier
himself is under pressure because there
are some states in the eu who believe
that he's actually too willing to
compromise and that may well be a result
of actually being in the room physically
with the uk negotiators because they're
making a pretty
stringent argument let's say on fishing
rights we know that's what this all
comes down to now the uk side saying
well it's only fair we're an independent
country we want ultimate control over
our fishing on our borders it's quite
hard to argue with that
even though michelle barnier wants to
push back on it for the eu state's sake
well they're going to be going to the
commons in just a moment of course
they're still meeting virtually and i
suppose
listening to the experts this morning
saying it's going to be spring at the
earliest
before that you can talk about the
vaccine actually having an effect on
on normal life and not spreading disease
they'll be carrying on like that in
parliament for some time
i would have thought so because there
has been this ongoing argument about
parliament showing the way and that's
why they're very keen on social
distancing when voting happens and to
try and make sure that people wear masks
when they're on the parliamentary estate
essentially
the uk government and the opposition
other parties setting the example
so it's likely that we won't see that
kind of raucous vibe
that we've had in prime minister's
questions for some time but that's
actually really important because on a
day like today when the prime minister
wants to walk into the commons to a big
cheer from his back benches particularly
after what happened last night
he won't get it and we know that boris
johnson is a performer he likes to have
that wall of noise behind him
and it may affect him more than it does
kierstrama i mean this this rebellion
yesterday i mean he's got a majority of
80. so 50
mps or more than 50 56 rebelled that
would mean
in a straight vote he wouldn't have a
majority anymore
but the opposition abstain and i mean
how how debilitating do you think it is
for him to have suffered this well in
terms of what actually happened as a
result the fact that the measures got
through not vary but in terms of the
politics it's very damaging because the
prime minister
is at a time when he needs this party
behind him the most he's
suffering you know dealing with the
pandemic it's been going on for a year
now
people in the country are very tired of
it they need to know the decisions being
made here in westminster are the right
ones
they are losing faith that the
government is making the right decisions
so it is absolutely essential for the
prime minister to have his party behind
him because
as i said at the start if he can't
convince his own mps that it's the right
deal they are there because of him
for him and with him and it's really
hard to make that argument to the
country
and their grievance the rebels yesterday
uh what we're going to hear now uh may
be from some uh
rebels uh promises questions getting
underway mr speaker today i'm proudly
wearing purple to celebrate
international day for disabled people
which is of course tomorrow
next year we will publish our national
strategy
for disabled people which will be the
most ambitious intervention in this area
for
a generation putting fairness at the
heart of the government's work
and leveling up so that everybody has
the opportunity to fully uh fully to
participate in the life of this country
mr speaker i know that the whole house
will want to join me in
welcoming the fantastic news that the
mhra
has formally authorized the pfizer
vaccine for kovid19
the vaccine i will begin to be made
available across the uk
from next week i would like to pay
tribute to and to thank all those who
have made this possible
it is the protection of vaccines that
will ultimately
allow us to reclaim our lives and get
our economy moving again mr speaker this
morning i had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others in addition to my
duties in this house i shall have
further such meetings later
today chris green thank you um speaker
i'd like to uh
share the congratulations with the prime
minister on the creation of this uh new
vaccine
and the speed with which it's got out
and to give that congratulations
especially to the
engineers technicians and scientists who
have delivered it now i believe that we
should support the widest
distribution and take up of safe and
effective
medicines but does my rightful friend
agree with me
that it should always be taken on a
wholly voluntary basis
by individuals and families
absolutely mr speaker i i strongly urge
people to to take up the vaccine but it
is no part of our uh culture or our
ambition in this country
uh to make uh vaccines mandatory that's
not how we do things
we now come to the leader of the
opposition writer of okay start now
thank you mr speaker can i join the
prime minister and his comments on
disabled
people and like the prime minister can i
start with the fantastic news about the
licensing of a
vaccine this pandemic has caused so much
grief and so much loss but we're now a
big step closer to the end of the
tunnel and like the prime minister can i
express my thanks those of everyone in
these branches
and across the house to all the
scientists who've worked on this
and to everybody who's taken part in the
trials
delivering a vaccine fairly quickly and
safely will now be the next major
challenge
facing the country and whatever our
differences across this house
we've all a duty to play our part in
this national effort
and to reassure the public about the
safety of the vaccine
mr speaker this morning a priority list
has been published for the first phase
of the rollout
we understand that around 800 000 doses
will soon be available and that's good
news because of the
two doses that will be required that
means 400 000 people can be vaccinated
in the first batch so can the prime
minister tell the house
who does he expect to receive the
vaccine next week
minister uh i'm i'm grateful to the
right honourable gentleman
uh uh for his uh his point about the the
rollout and he's
he's he let me uh perhaps i've just had
to update the house on
what the jc vi has concluded so far
and uh the priority list will be
residents in a care home
uh for adults for older adults and their
carers to stop
uh transmission uh all those uh 80 years
of age and
older front-line healthcare
and social care workers then all those
of 75 years of age and over
then all those of 70 years of age and
over
the clinically extremely vulnerable
individuals uh
and and then a a a list that i'm sure
the house will want to to study
closely but i believe does represent uh
common sense i think it is very
important at this stage
for us all to recognize that this is uh
unquestionably
good news it's very very good news but
it is by no means
the end of the story it is not the end
of our national
uh struggle against uh against
coronavirus and that is why it's very
important
that the package of moderate but tough
measures that uh the house voted for
last night the tiering system is
followed across the country
because that's how we will continue uh
to beat the virus
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
referenced the priority for the first
phase and as he said the top two
priority groups are residents in care
homes for older adults and their carers
all those 80 years of age and over in
front line health and social care
workers i'm not criticizing that list in
the slightest but it's obvious that
that's more than 400
000 people and the prime minister will
understand how anxious people in those
particular groups are
after having sacrificed so much so can
the prime minister tell us
the answer the question that they're
going to be asking this morning which is
when does he expect that
all people in those two top groups can
expect to be vaccinated
prime minister uh mr speaker
uh i i think it's at this stage it is
very very important that uh people
do not uh get their hopes up
too soon about the speed with which we
will be able to uh roll out this vaccine
it is
uh beginning as uh my right on from the
whole secretary has said
uh from next week we are expecting
several million
uh doses of the fisa beyond tech
vaccine before the end of the year we
will then
be rolling it out as fast as as we
possibly can
but that's why i put so much emphasis mr
speaker on
the continuing importance of the tiering
system uh
of mass uh community testing at the same
time as we go forward
through these tough winter months
because we will need at the same time as
we roll out the vaccine and he's right
to ask about
about time doubles but as we as we roll
out the vaccine over the next few weeks
mr speaker we will need to keep that
tough tiering
and testing regimes in place good stuff
thank you mr speaker can i press the
prime minister a bit further about the
plan for
care homes i do so because we all want
this to work because that top category
is residency and care homes
and that'll always be a huge concern for
many people this morning the welsh
government has already raised some
serious practical problems
about the delivery of vaccines into care
homes that's bearing in mind the
temperatures at which the vaccines have
to be stored
now the prime minister must know this is
going to be a four nation
problem uh must be aware that this
problem would arise
um and obviously we will want to
overcome this problem and it's in that
spirit that i asked the prime minister
what plans has he put in place to
address these particular problems
of getting the vaccine safely and
quickly into care homes
given the practical difficulties of
doing so the anxiety
that those in care homes will have about
getting it quickly prime minister
well uh he uh he is entirely right to
raise the issue of
uh of care homes and the uh ability our
ability to distribute
uh this particular type of vaccine
rapidly
uh into care homes because it does need
to be kept at minus
70 degrees as i think the house
understands so there are
logistical challenges to be overcome to
to get vulnerable people
uh the access to the vaccine that uh
that they need
uh we are working on it with all four
uh all the all the devolved
administrations uh in order to
uh ensure that the nhs across the
country
is able and it's the nhs that will be in
the lead is able to
distribute it as as fast and uh
as sensibly as possible to the most
vulnerable groups but he
he's right to raise that uh particular
logistical difficulty
that's why it's also important uh that
we get
the astrazeneca uh vaccine uh which we
hope will also
come on stream and uh while he's while
he's paying tribute
to uh those who've been involved in the
vaccines perhaps he could
also pay tribute uh to the work of the
vaccine task force
uh which secured the deal with pfizer
and which uh
he uh i think criticized only a few
weeks ago
well i pay tribute to everybody who's
got us this far and we'll work with all
of them to get us where we need to go
next this has to be something which we
all pull together to deliver this
as quickly and safely as possible over
the next few months and i've made that
offer to the prime minister
before and i do it again can i and it's
really in that vein i turn to the next
question which is public confidence in
the vaccine which is a real cause
for concern because that's going to be
crucial to the success
of getting this rolled out across the
country getting our economy back up and
running as the prime minister knows
we've got the highest regulatory and
medical safety standards
in the world but it's really important
we do everything possible to
to counter dangerous frankly
life-threatening disinformation
about vaccines we on this side have
called for legislation to be introduced
to clamp down on this
with financial penalties for companies
that fail to act
so will the prime minister work with us
on this and bring forward emergency
legislation in the coming days
which i think the whole house would
support prime minister
[Applause]
well uh mr speaker we are of course uh
working to tackle
all kinds of disinformation across the
uh the internet and uh he's right to
single out
the the the anti-vaxxers and those who i
think are totally wrong
uh in their approach and uh he's right
to encourage take-up of vaccines
across the across the country and uh
we'll be publishing a paper very shortly
mr speaker
on online harms uh designed to tackle
the very disinformation that he that he
speaks of thank you
mr speaker can i also urge the prime
minister once the government has a
communications plan for the vaccine can
he share it with the house
so we can all say the same thing in the
same way to the country and thus
encourage as many people to take up the
vaccine as possible
now the arrival of vaccine is obviously
wonderful news but it will come
too late to many who've lost their jobs
already and i want to turn to the
collapse of the arcadia group
and debenhams in the last 48 hours
that's put 25 000 jobs at risk
and obviously caused huge anxiety to
many families at the worst possible time
and threatens to rip the heart out of
many high streets in our towns and
cities
so can the prime minister tell the house
what is he going to do
now to protect the jobs and the pensions
of all those affected by these closures
uh mr speaker we're looking at what we
can do to protect
uh all the jobs that are being lost to
currently across the country and uh
my radon friend the secretary of state
for uh business advising skills has
written to
uh the insolvency service to look at the
conduct of the arcadia
uh directors uh uh and uh we will be
we will be doing everything we can to
restore
uh the high streets of this country uh
with our one billion pound
uh high streets uh fund and the leveling
up fund mr speaker but i must say
i think it is it is a bit much the the
right honourable gentleman should uh
attack the economic consequences of the
fight against
coronavirus when last night neither he
nor his troops could be bothered to vote
for measures
uh sensible balance measures that would
open up the economy
and allow allow businesses to to trade
mr speaker
how can he attack the economic
consequences of our battle against
coronavirus when he won't even support
measures to open up the economy
[Applause]
mr speaker when i abstain i come to the
house
and explain when the prime minister when
the prime minister abstains he runs away
to afghanistan
and gives the taxpayer a 20 000 pound
bill mr speaker on the question of jobs
there are serious questions that need to
be answered about the collapse of these
businesses
uh and i don't want the prime minister
to deflect from that and what it means
for these many families
because this isn't an isolated incident
over 200 000 retail
jobs have been lost this year that's 200
000
individuals and their families 20 000
stores have been closed on our high
street
and that's before the latest
restrictions now i suspect
if we'd seen that scale of job losses in
any other sector
that would have been much greater action
already so i urge the prime minister to
take this seriously don't
deflect as well as providing emergency
support
will the prime minister work with us
with the trade unions and the sector
to finally bring forward a comprehensive
plan to save retail jobs
and to provide the sector with the much
greater support it needs through this
crisis
these are real people prime minister
with real jobs this family
who are facing the sack they really need
to hear from you
prime minister speaker we're of course
supporting every job that we possibly
can as we're supporting every life and
every livelihood mr speaker with a 200
billion pound program but i
take him more seriously frankly if he
actually could be bothered to vote
for a program a moderate program to to
keep the virus down
and open up the economy uh mr speaker
and
we're getting on we're getting on with
our program as i say of rolling out the
vaccine of uh of sensible
tiering measures in addition to which mr
speaker we are delivering
40 more hospitals and 20 000 uh more
police officers
and he talks about abstention mr speaker
when it came to protecting
our veterans uh from unfair prosecution
he chose
uh to abstain uh when it came when it
came to protecting the people of this
country
from when it came to protecting the
people of this country from
coronavirus at this critical moment he
told
his troops to abstain mr speaker
captain hindsight is rising rapidly up
the ranks has become general
indecision mr speaker
[Music]
that's that's what's happening i'm
afraid to the right honourable gentleman
he he
mr speaker next week marks one year
since the prime minister won a mighty
majority
his bold vision turned the red wall
bloom
ensuring our communities would no longer
be neglected
as part of the pm's plan to level up a
new infrastructure bank has been
promised
mr speaker you know wakefield is the
crossroads of the kingdom
our cathedral spire the tallest in god's
own country
and historically the principal city of
west yorkshire and the pulsating
oxygenating heart of the red wall all
make it the perfect city for the new
band's home
will my right honourable friend the
prime minister commit to establish the
new infrastructure bank
in wakefield and restore my city's glory
well my my honourable friend is a
magnificent doubting campaigner for
wakefield and i know that my writer will
defend
the chancellor and listen very closely
to his uh his
uh call for the national infrastructure
bank to be established in
uh in wakefield and he should uh wait on
events mr speaker
let's head up to scotland with the
leader of the smp in blackford
in blackfoot thank you mr speaker this
morning for the
first time in months people have woken
up with a genuine sense of hope
the news and the vaccine approval is the
news that we've all been waiting for
but mr speaker for many that hope on the
horizon
remains far too distant there are
millions who still haven't had
a single penny of support from this uk
government
as others rightly received help they
receive none
prime minister yesterday i met with
excluded uk
who represent many of these three
million citizens
for the last nine months the excluded
have been living without any help
without any hope
and it is now tragically costing lives
prime minister they told me something
genuinely shocking they are aware of
eight people
who have taken their lives in the last
10 days
eight people in ten days
prime minister we're now a little over
three weeks from christmas
these people need help will the prime
minister
commit to looking again at the support
package for the excluded
to ensure no one but no one is left
behind
prime minister well i i obviously
sympathize very much mr speaker with uh
those who've taken their lives and their
families and
this has been a very tough time for the
country we're investing massively
in uh in mental health support uh across
the
uh the country as as he knows uh which
is flows through environment
consequentials to obviously to
uh to scotland and we put in a huge
package of support
and he knows this but i must repeat this
for for self-employed people
across the country i know there are hard
to reach uh people but they are also
supported
with the increases in uh in universal
credit and the many other means
of support that are currently on offer
mr speaker and
i think when you look at the overall
level of support this cut this
government has given
to people across this country it
compares favorably with any other
government
around the world returning to in
blackford in blackfoot
i have to say and i do this with regret
mr speaker that simply isn't good enough
these people
need help and i'm asking the prime
minister to think very carefully about
this
this has been an abject failure by this
uk government
and the prime minister has been missing
in action
the government has u-turned and almost
everything else so why can't the prime
minister
and the chancellor change their minds on
their support for these three million
people
these are people working in construction
creative industries events
education hospitality retail and health
care
they haven't just been left behind
they've been ignored for nine months
the chancellor has repeatedly dogged
this issue
excluded uk haven't been offered one
formal meeting
with the government minister will the
prime minister commit today
to a meeting and working with excluded
uk on a meaningful package of support
or is the prime minister simply going to
abandon these people
three weeks from christmas prime
minister
mr speaker we've abandoned nobody and
we're continuing to support people we'll
continue
we we have we have announced uh nearly
four in addition to the support i've
already mentioned we've announced
uh nearly 400 400 million to support
vulnerable children and their families
uh through the through the winter uh
we've increased universal credit as i
just mentioned
uh to the housing increased local uh
housing alliance
provided uh billions more to uh local
authorities to
help those who are who are hard to reach
but i may say to the
to the right honourable gentleman that
the best way to help the self-employed
uh to help the economy of this whole
country is to get
is to get us moving again uh with the
with the package of
measures that the house voted for last
night
uh to to allow him to allow retail
uh to start up again uh to allow
business uh to start up again the
gentleman for the scottish actually said
it's shameful uh
we on this side of the house do not
think retail is shameful mr speaker
uh we we want we we we want we want
businesses to open up again mr speaker
and that is the that is the nature of
the package that was voted for last
night
which was i think was quite right it was
a great great shame that the right
honourable gentleman opposite could not
bring himself
to support it thank you mr speaker at
this time of enormous pressure on
our healthcare can i welcome the
government and the nhs
continued commitment to the new combined
medical facility in edenbridge
now can he confirm to me that the sale
of the existing
memorial hospital which was built by
public donation about a century ago
will now help fund the new building now
he's investing
20 million pounds in the medicines
manufacturing fund
to benefit wales scotland england and
northern ireland
so will he join me in welcoming the
skill of all those
in the nhs and indeed the health
secretary
in making historic donations work for
our communities today
prime minister uh well yes i can mr
speaker but uh
and i i congratulate him on his campaign
any
uh decision uh to allow for the sale of
the hospital is of course a matter of
the local
ccg but uh i know that
uh he is fully supporting the the 12
million pound
uh that we put in for the development of
a new health and well-being center for
eden bridge
let's head to wales with liz savile
robert
liz savile roberts
and first of all i'd like to add my
voice to welcome the licensing of the
vaccine this really is
a ray of light and dark times but
last week his governments published
their statement of funding showing a
reduction in the amount wales receives
through transport spend in england from
80.9
to 36.6 this reveals in black
and white the iniquity of the rail
betrayal being inflicted on wales
welsh taxpayers are paying for english
transport and hs2
but we don't get a fair return could he
inform the house
how much investment he is funneling away
from wales
due to his government's decision to
label this white elephant
an england and wales scheme despite not
a single inch the railway being in wales
prime minister sorry uh mrs b i
certainly failed to recognize the
the the the characterization that the uh
the writer of the lady
makes of of investment across the whole
of the of the uk the welsh government
will receive an additional 1.3 billion
pounds
uh next year we're providing 240 million
more to support welsh farmers
uh 2.1 million support fisheries in
uh in in wales and uh the last time
uh i looked at the transport in wales
there were they
the welsh labor government spent 144
million pounds
on uh plans uh for a bypass of an m4
bypass which they then jumped uh mr
speaker
robin miller thank you mr speaker the
people of abercon we would like to thank
the prime minister for his early
christmas present
and this vaccine like many presidents we
might not have made it but this
government
this union could afford to buy it for
this country
um mr speaker i was in stand roost this
saturday talking with small businesses
who've had to deal with flooding in
february and the pandemic since march
all they want to do is trade so will my
right honourable friend join me in
thanking
shop vlodai shopjohn ed and emma james
cakes
for battling through a really difficult
2020
and does he agree that this news of a
vaccine and its licensing
gives real hope to these three women
these three entrepreneurs
and thousands like them across the uk
hope for a better 2021. thank you
prime minister uh yes indeed mr speaker
i congratulate the three
uh female entrepreneurs that he uh that
he mentions
and they will be helped uh they will be
helped by the by the vaccine and they
will be allowed to
uh to do business again and what a shame
it is mr speaker that
our our program was sensibly safely to
open up the economy
wasn't supported by the right honourable
gentleman let's head up to preston with
sir mark hendrick
so mark mr speaker the prime minister
has put at risk the good friday
agreement and peace
in northern ireland after promising the
people of this country he wouldn't
he promised the country a world-beating
test track and trace system
and conveniently forgotten to provide
the track and trace part of the promise
he promised an oven ready deal with the
eu to win the 2019
general election and we look like having
no deal when will the prime minister
follow through and deliver on his
promises
instead of behaving like a second-hand
car salesman
prime minister well if the if if the if
the honorable gentleman
is uh saying that he wants to
keep this country in the eu then which i
think was a gist of i mean
what he was saying mr speaker then he's
going to be sorely uh disappointed
and so and so will the party opposite
but because
thank you mr speaker they said that
britain was a nation of shopkeepers and
in stockton
we're proud to have some of the best
retailers in the country
they've had a tough year they're
grateful for the support they've
received from the government
but remain concerned about the future of
business rates
can my honourable friend confirm that
the government remains committed
to a fundamental review of business
rates and will he join me in encouraging
people
to get down the local high street and
shop local this christmas
yes i'm going to stir uh yes indeed mr
speaker
my uncle reminds me it is small business
saturday uh
this this saturday and everybody should
be uh should be shopping
uh local uh but i can also i can also
tell him that
the treasury is considering responses to
the call for evidence uh on
business rates ahead of the reviews
conclusion
in the spring alex davis mr speaker
we all know it will take a long time for
many industries to recover from the
impact of coronavirus
the aviation sector and its supply chain
which supports almost a quarter of a
million jobs
has been uniquely impacted many workers
and their families at ge aviation in
pontepre have been financially ruined
and i know that this is sadly a familiar
scenario for families up and down the
country
the prime minister urgently needs to
wake up to the situation
so will he therefore commit to a
sector-specific support deal
to save our aviation industry before
it's too late
prime minister uh well mr speaker we
were doing
a huge amount to support our aviation
industry but i appreciate the
the the stress and difficulties that
many families are in at the moment
because of the
uh the threats to that sector which are
which are global
alas because people just aren't flying
in the way that they were before the
pandemic
but i have every hope that it will
bounce back very strongly particularly
in this country which is a
world leader in aviation once we get the
economy
moving again as i hope we can dr liam
fault
thank you mr speaker in north somerset
as in the rest
of the united kingdom small businesses
are the lifeblood of the economy
providing
over 60 percent of all our jobs post
covered we will require a private sector
small business led recovery can i ask
the prime minister if he will consider a
new discipline
within the government in the form of a
small business test
so that every tax every regulation and
every bit of legislation
is uh measured against whether or not it
will provide support
for this sector which will be vital for
our post-covered recovery
prime minister well uh mr speaker i can
i
i thank him for uh his excellent
suggestion and he's a great champion of
uh of small business every measure the
government uh produces is judged
by the effect of the impact it will have
on uh businesses large and
small mr speaker but we're also
providing as he knows for these
particularly difficult circumstances
about a billion 100 billion pounds of uh
of business support
uh the balanced backed loans and many
other forms of support but the best
thing
uh for businesses large and small uh
shop local as i said
uh earlier on and allow the economy uh
cautiously
and and prudently to reopen louisville
thank you very much mr speaker i want to
congratulate the prime minister as think
next week
marks his first year in post however in
that time
over 71 000 covered deaths the highest
rate in europe
over 2 trillion in debt the worst
performing economy in the g7
failing brexit negotiations and at least
1.5 billion of taxpayers money spent on
contracts to tory friends and donors
whilst at the same time whipping his mps
to vote against meals for hungry
children
which one of these achievements is he
most proud of prime minister
well i i think what uh what she i i take
her point more seriously if
uh she and her party uh could be
bothered uh to vote for measures
uh that will that will symbols oh well
they're so social i'm sorry she defied
she defied the labour whip forgive me mr
speaker she defied the injunction to
dither
uh from uh from the ditherer in chief
but it'd be a good thing
it would be a good thing she couldn't
didn't obey you didn't didn't it
didn't day's instructions to dinner uh
but it would be i i take i take her more
seriously mr speaker if her party leader
would vote for measures uh that would
open up the economy
whilst protecting uh lives across the uk
let's head to lincoln with carl
mccartney carl mccartney
good afternoon speaker i would like to
thank my honourable friend and his
cabinet colleagues for last week
granting my request to fund the north
hike and relief road the final part of
eastern bypass
around my constituency of lincoln i look
forward to seeing internal combustion
engine vehicles
gliding over its smooth tile max surface
for many many decades to come
as the prime minister will know my
constituents have been clear to me on
recent decisions on lockdown in the tier
and the new tier system as they normally
and refreshingly are
making sure is a very big space and so
despite my county colleagues succumbing
to the wiley charms
of the secretary of state for health
last night will my right honourable
friend seriously consider allowing local
decision makers the chance
to set tier systems locally after all
local decision makers know their patches
far better than any whitehall official
local businesses in lincoln including
some excluded uk members
who've yet to receive any support are
desperate to get back to work
and to fire up our uk economy
prime minister uh well i i repeat what i
said to the house several times
yesterday afternoon i'm grateful to
my honourable friend uh of course we
want to reflect local conditions as
closely
and accurately as we can in taking our
decisions about
tiering but we must look at the entire
national picture and i'm just uh
on on his point about internal
combustion engines i just remind him
that a
hydrogen engine can also be an internal
combustion engine
wendy chamberlain thank you mr speaker
my constituent was diagnosed with me
in 2019 and earlier this year her
employer agreed that she was no longer
able to work
and to do the job she loved she applied
for pip but the dwp has ruled that she
is fit
to work they've not engaged with her
previous employer who have a wealth of
evidence to the country
and used it to reach its own decision
her life has been devastated by this
diagnosis she told me the pit process is
predicted on being able to stand up for
yourself
and as a disabled person i cannot do
this so will the prime minister
meet with me to ensure that our benefit
system works for sufferers of chronic
fatigue
and does not limit decisions to single
points of evidence
yeah prime minister i'm grateful for her
question she's raising
an important issue i know that many
people suffer from the syndrome that she
uh she describes and i'll ensure that
she gets a proper
representation proper meeting with the
relevant minister to just to discuss
uh the uh her objectives let's head to
north cornwall with scotland
scott mum thank you mr speaker
some in the media only discuss leveling
up through the prism of the north-south
divide
however cornwall has pockets of
deprivation and many communities
in my constituency of northcorn will
also need investment and support so i
welcome the government's announcement
of the four billion pound leveling up
fund and the decision to review
the green book so that projects outside
of london and the south east
are more likely to benefit from
government investment however
in light of the new spending commitments
can my right honourable friend confirm
that the shared prosperity fund is
separate to the leveling up fund
but there will be an announcement on
that soon and it will be simpler
and less time consuming for small
businesses to access than the onerous
eu schemes they are replacing prime
minister uh yes
yes indeed mr speaker i thank the uh my
honorable friend because he's completely
right
uh about the importance of uh the new uk
uh shared prosperity fund it will be
different from the uh the leveling up
fund
and uh we're gonna work closely with uh
with with him
and uh with people in cornwall uh to
make sure that we use the
additional funding best for the needs of
people and communities in cornwall
richard thompson thank you mr speaker
this week the scottish government
announced a 500
bonus scheme for our health and social
care heroes who've helped us
care for us through the pandemic that's
a policy that the scottish conservatives
have been trying to
claim some credit reflected credit for
over the last few hours
now the prime minister is not
responsible for health in scotland
but he is responsible for it in england
so will he put his government's money
where his scottish colleagues mouths
clearly are and match that initiative
bonus initiative for health and social
care workers in england
and will he instruct the chancellor that
whatever a bonus scheme like that is
introduced
that the treasury will not try to
snaffle back the tax from it and let it
be paid
tax-free yeah prime minister well uh
on the last point of course that's a
matter for the scottish government
which has the fiscal freedom uh to to do
that but i
thank health and social care workers i
thank health and social care workers in
scotland
and across the the whole country and i'm
i'm proud of the increases that we've
been able to put in
12.8 percent over the last three years
uh and uh a million pay rise for a
million people in the
uh in the nhs as part of the biggest
ever investment in the nhs
uh even before kovid began an investment
that will
continue under this government let's
head to ludlow with philip dunn
phillip in 10 days time the government
is hosting the un
climate summit ahead of cop 26 next year
i urge the prime minister not to curb
your enthusiasm for the environment
and will he show international
leadership by setting out an ambitious
but achievable target for emissions in
2030
as the uk's nationally determined
contribution on the path to net zero
britain
prime minister well i'm private mr
speaker that the uk led the way
in instituting a uh target of net zero
by
uh by 2050 of all the developed nations
we were the
uh we were the first and uh we're
looking at our uh our national
uh nationally determined contribution
which will be extremely ambitious and
will be
published around the time of the uh the
climate summit on the 12th
of december this year final question
heading to scotland with drew hendrick
drew hendrick
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
mentioned universal credit earlier
his and is the chancellor's decision to
increase universal credit by 20 pounds a
week during the pandemic
was an admission of what my constituents
have known for years
the universal credit simply isn't enough
to live on
in january his government will cap the
benefits of thousands
of universal credit claimants the
average losses will be 250 pounds per
month
mainly to families with children he
already knows
it's not enough to live on so will he
now commit to scrap the cap
and to guarantee to continue the 20
pounds per week uplift
or is he going to throw these families
to the wolves too
just like the three million excluded
prime minister uh i'm really mr speaker
i just repeat the point i made
earlier on about the huge sums the
government has invested in in
looking after families lives and
livelihoods across the whole of the uk
well north of 200 billion pounds
now an uplift of universal credit as he
rightly says
of a thousand pounds and we will
continue to support
uh families across this country
throughout
the pandemic but the objective must be
is i hope he would agree
to get the economy moving again
and get people back into work in the way
that i think everybody would want and it
is a fact mr speaker
that uh under this government uh in
spite of all the difficulties we have
faced the unemployment rate
is lower in the uk than it is in in
france and spain
in italy uh in canada and the united
states
and uh we will continue to work to look
after every job that we can
in order to allow the safe exit
vulnerable members participating in this
item of business
and the safe arrival of those
participants well that is uh prime
minister's questions uh
boris johnson really having quite a hard
time and not even managing to have the
few mps in the chamber on his side quite
a lot of open laughing at him
uh he uh did say uh that
uh the rollout will begin next week but
he said don't get your hopes up that it
will be available
too soon uh his main thrust appeared to
be to
attack uh the leader of the opposition
for
having labour abstain yesterday calling
him captain hindsight
changing to general in decision
also questioned about progress on brexit
he said that anyone who wanted to stop
brexit is going to be disappointed
uh we'll have more on that in a moment
but i should just bring you up to date
with some other developments the world
health organization the who
has announced that it's going to get in
touch with the british regulatory
authorities in the hope that it can
provide information
which will lead to a speed up of who uh
approval of the beyond tech fisa vaccine
uh also uh following comments from
uh british ministers particularly alok
sharma that this was
a uk breakthrough the german uh health
minister has retorted that this was a
european
uh discovery uh now we're going to hear
uh in a moment from the business
secretary alex sharma asking answering
an urgent question from
his shadow ed miliband about a support
for business particularly following
the collapse of arcadia and debenhams
but uh kate mccann
what was your impression of that prime
minister's questions i mean it should
have been
a really good day for boris johnson it
should have been and i thought his tone
was really interesting because you
picked up on it there one of the second
things i think he said to kierstama was
that people need to be very cautious and
being too optimistic about the speed of
the rollout
and we know that he appointed a vaccine
minister last week so clearly the
government is thinking
about how this happens but i get the
sense from what the prime minister was
saying today that actually he doesn't
want people to
throw away all of the restrictions to
ignore the new tiered system
of course it comes in on exactly the
same day ultimately the vaccine will
help move away from those restrictions
but if people ignore them and start to
do their own thing too
soon they may well not get vaccinated
until next spring and that's a long time
for the virus to potentially spread
if people don't pay attention to the
rules i think kyocera's questioning was
really
interesting because he was asking a lot
of practical information particularly on
what we were talking about earlier on
care homes and the fact that fires are
beyond tech needs to be stored at -70
it's stable for we think five days
according to pfizer
but the welsh government's saying that
they don't believe they can roll it out
to care homes
the prime minister was asked
specifically on that point didn't give
any actual detail
but did say that the government was
doing everything it could to ensure the
vulnerable get it first
and ian blackford also picking up on the
detail
talking about those people a lot of them
self-employed
such as construction workers and people
working in entertainment
who haven't had any support let's go now
to
the question from ed miliband make a
statement on support for business and
the retention
of jobs on the high street in light of
the announcement of arcadia entering
administration
and debenhams going into liquidation
minister paul scully
yeah thank you madam deputy speaker and
as the retail minister i hope he
realizes that uh the
the secretary of state is not here that
we do take this incredibly importantly
and that's why
um because it is a that's why why i want
to focus on the
the detail because it is a worrying time
for the retail sector particularly by
those that are affected by the
announcements made last this week
on monday arcadia group limited which
employs approximately 13
000 people appointed administrators and
they are assessing
all options available to the group
they'll honor orders made over the black
friday weekend
no redundancies have yet been announced
and existing sales channels will
continue to operate
while administrators evaluate options
the secretary of state has written to
the insolvency services
and ask that they expedite consideration
of the administrator's report
yesterday debenhams which employs
approximately 12 000 people
announced the decision of administrators
to wind down the company
no redundancies have been announced and
existing sales channels will continue to
operate while administrators evaluate
options
we know this is going to be a worrying
time for employees and their families
and we stand ready
to support them i want to pay
particularly tribute to the hard-working
staff
who have kept these well-recognised
businesses going in difficult times for
so long
while government has no role in the
strategic direction or management of
private retail companies we're in
regular contact with both companies
and the administrators to fully
understand the situation they are facing
the coronavirus crisis has made life
difficult for many high street retailers
like arcadia and debenhams particularly
those who are already facing challenging
trading conditions before the pandemic
we acted quickly at the at the start of
the pandemic to develop deliver one of
the most generous and comprehensive
economic packages in the world
including the coronavirus job retention
scheme which up to the 30th of september
had provided 7.7
billion pounds worth of support to
companies in the retail and wholesale
sector
removing all eligible properties in the
retail prop in the retail hospitality
and leisure sectors from business rates
for 12 months worth over
10 billion pounds cash grants for up to
25 000 pounds for retail
hospitality and leisure businesses with
a ratable value of between 15 000
and 51 000 pounds and more than 50
billion pounds in business
loans which supported 9.6 million jobs
and provided flexibility
with also legislation to protect
commercial terms for eviction
and through the plan for jobs we've
announced a series of measures to
protect
support and create jobs including our
two billion pound kickstart scheme
and doubling the number of frontline
work coaches which will be important
in this situation in particular the
government is committed to support the
retail sector
and we're working closely with industry
through these unprecedented times
particularly to ensure safe reopening
non-essential retail
today on monday my right on will friend
the community secretary
encourage local authorities to allow
shops to open for extended hours
to accommodate more shoppers safely in
the lead up to christmas
i'll continue to work with the sector to
meet future challenges
indeed i'll be co-chairing the next
meeting of the retail sector council
tomorrow
to discuss our strategic approach to the
sector and i have regular retail calls
uh including one last week with
representative from arcadia amongst the
retailers on that call
we are confident that the sector has the
skills the knowledge and drive to bounce
back
secretary of state ed miliband
let me join the minister in expressing
deep sympathy for those who are at risk
of losing their jobs the test of
government and indeed this house is
whether that sympathy translates into
action
so i have four specific questions for
him first
philip green owes the workers at arcadia
a moral duty
his family took a dividend worth 1.2
billion pounds from the company
the largest in uk history more than
three times the size of the pension
deficit
the workers at arcadia should not pay
the price of philip
green's greed so will the minister now
publicly call for him to make good
any shortfall in the pension scheme and
will he ensure that the pensions
regulator takes all possible steps to
make sure
this happens second we need to learn
lessons madam deputy speaker
in the insolvency bill in the summer
labour put forward amendments
to make pension fund holders priority
creditors
when businesses went bust the minister
said it was not necessary
does he agree now that that was a
mistake that this change would have
better protected the pensions
at arcadia and that this should be put
right through legislation in the future
third on the workers at dublin's
debenhams and indeed arcadia
facing redundancy given the scale of
redundancies and the grim
economic backdrop will he look at
providing specific and targeted
help for them to get back into work
fourth we have an emergency on our high
streets with an estimated 20
000 shops closing and 200 000 workers
losing their jobs
since the economic crisis began
while we support well we won't welcome
the support that has been provided will
he recognize
the government must do more extending
the rent evictions moratorium
beyond december when it is due to expire
increasing support for hospitality
businesses which was a call across this
house
yesterday and addressing the massive
disadvantage that high street businesses
face around business rates compared to
online
retailers madam deputy speaker today is
a day of great news on the vaccine
but the government has a massive
responsibility to preserve
the businesses and jobs we need on the
other side of this crisis
they are still not acting on a scale
that meets the economic emergency
our country faces they need to do so
minister i'm grateful for
the right honourable uh gentleman for
raising some really important points
here in terms of
the um uh pension schemes and support
for those facing redundancy
the majority of defined pension schemes
are run effectively we're fortunate to
have a robust
flexible system of pension protection in
the uk
the independent pension regulator has a
range of powers
to protect pension schemes and it does
work closely with those involved
for schemes where the employer goes
insultant the pension protection fund is
there to help
protect the members anybody already in
receipt of the pensions will continue to
be paid and other members will receive
at least pension protection fund
compensation levels uh the the pension
protection fund is confident that its
funding plan and investment approach
position
position it well to weather the current
market volatility of future challenges
it wouldn't be appropriate at this stage
uh for ministers to comment on
individual cases
which are a matter of for the regulator
but in
respect to the staff facing possible
redundancy the dwp rapid response
service has been
in ongoing conversations already with
debenhams and has now been in contact
with arcadia
both have been offered support by the
rapid response service which includes
connecting people to jobs
in the labour market helping with job
search including cv writing
interview skills where to write fine
jobs and how to apply
for them helping to identify
transferable skills and skills gaps
linked to the local
labor market and what benefits they may
get and how to claim
i've talked about the front er the fact
that we've doubled the number of work um
place uh support staff in jobcentre
pluses and clearly
with uh knowing where those the big
stores are for developments in
particular
um then we will be able to offer that
sort of target support
the right and uh member talked about uh
uh the
uh that proposed to his proposed changes
for the corporate governance and
solvency
practice bill and this was a matter of
balance because elevating pension debts
which
can often be quite large will therefore
in its in by
its very nature dilute um the the
uh amount that's that is available to
trade and credit suppliers
but also other suppliers including
people with unpaid wages so it's trying
to get that
complexity and balance that is right he
finally
talks about hospitality and support for
other other sectors now clearly the high
street is an ecosystem
it's not just all about shops in retail
we need to make sure that we are doing
as much as we can
to continue to wrap our economy uh our
arms around the economy at this
particularly challenging time especially
as he acknowledges that there is light
at the top at the end of the tunnel
but we must not take our foot of the gas
we must not we must remain
alert in terms of our own behaviors as
as community members going up and down
the high street shopping local where we
can to support retailers as they as they
remain open
but also as a government to make sure
that we can support retailers and
hospitality sectors
both in the support that i mentioned but
also in encouraging them to be able to
trade and remain open
in all three tiers as best we can
suzanne
thank you well the minister paul scully
they're answering questions about the
collapse of arcadia
and uh demons but very much avoiding
specific questions particularly about
sir philip greene the
owner of arcadia there with me is our
political correspondent kate mccann but
you're pointing out something
interesting came up in passing in prime
minister's questions
yes in answer to zakir starmer in the
later stages of that
exchange the prime minister actually
said that there was an investigation
into the conduct of arcadia directors so
i checked it out with mark climb in our
city editor
who of course wrote the story expert on
these matters he says that the
insolvency service has launched an
investigation and notes that it is
actually standard in any insolvency for
that to be the case
but as you point out there are some
particular questions about philip green
his conduct and the size of dividends
that he's drawn out of that business
over the years that one that politicians
want to see addressed
whether they will be in this
investigation is another matter and this
question of government support for
business
very much becoming the fault line
between of the conservatives and indeed
the justification for the abstentions by
labour yesterday
yes and actually some conservative
backbenchers now are very very concerned
and it may well be a symptom of the fact
that they have spent more time in their
local constituencies than perhaps they
ever would have done given that they
usually are in westminster and in london
they are now seeing the disappearance of
these big businesses on their high
street i want to know what the prime
minister is doing about it
you heard him talking to scott mann a
conservative mp in pmqs about some of
the support that will come to local high
streets local businesses particularly
small business
but for these big high street businesses
debenhams arcadia group
the ones that we've seen on our high
streets for some time that's a much more
difficult question
because the size of them and what they
sell and their competitors
groups like asos that are online boohoo
giant fashion retailers that don't have
the stores to maintain
don't have the staffing costs that's the
question of actually a whole industry
and the way that it needs to change
because of technology